انهارت المباني تمامًا في وقت متأخر من
ليلة الجمعة، ويقول شهود إن الناس
محاصرون تحت الأنقاض،
وفر آلاف السكان إلى الشوارع
وأمضوا الليل في الخارج، حيث
حذر المسؤولون من هزات ارتدادية محتملة،
وتقول وزارة الداخلية إنه
تم تفعيل جميع الموارد المتاحة،
وتقول هيئة المسح الجيولوجي الأمريكية
كان الزلزال الذي بلغت قوته 6.8 درجة أحد أقوى الزلازل التي ضربت
المنطقة منذ أكثر من قرن في
وضح النهار أو في استراحة النهار، ولا يزال على بعد أكثر من
ساعة ونصف. حسنًا،
ينضم إلي الآن ديفيد والد،
وهو عالم زلازل في هيئة
المسح الجيولوجي الأمريكية، أه رائع
لنشاركك وخبرتك، زلزال بقوة 6.8 درجة،
ماذا يمكنك أن تخبرنا عن
قوة هذا الحجم، ما
هي إمكاناته،
الشيء المهم هو
قرب الاهتزاز من
السكان، لذا فهو زلزال متوسط ​​الحجم
ولكنه ضحل  وهي تقع في
منطقة مأهولة بالسكان إلى حد ما، لذا فهذه
مشكلة، والمكون الآخر
الذي يؤدي إلى الكارثة هو بالطبع
ضعف المباني وقد
بدأنا نرى ذلك الآن في
الأخبار التي تقدمها هناك
الكثير  من الهياكل الضعيفة، المنازل، كتلة
دوبي، الخرسانة غير المسلحة
والإطارات الخرسانية التي أه مع هذا
المستوى من الاهتزاز الذي تم الوصول إليه،
معرضة للخطر تمامًا، أخبرنا بما نعرفه
عن شكل المنطقة من حيث
النشاط الزلزالي لأنه على ما يبدو
هو أكبر زلزال
تعرفه  في قرن هذا
صحيح أه ولكن
بكمية قليلة فقط وبعض
الأحداث أه السابقة في المغرب عام 1960 و2004
بينما نحن أصغر في المناطق الأكثر كثافة سكانية
لذلك خلقوا قدرًا كبيرًا من
المشاكل في عام 1960 كان هناك 13  000
حالة وفاة بسبب زلزال أقرب إلى
أغادير كان من الواضح أنه مأهول
بالسكان، لذا فإن هذا الزلزال يقع بين
أغادير وأمريكا إلى
الشمال الشرقي أه وهو أقل سكانًا ولكن
أه زلزال كبير لذا هناك
مفاضلة بين حجم
الزلزال وحجم الزلزال  السكان لذا،
نعم، لا، لا، استمر جيدًا،
المنطقة بأكملها شمال شمال
أفريقيا معرضة للزلازل وأه
تاريخيًا كانت هناك
زلازل كثيرة بهذا الحجم ويعتمد ذلك
على مكان وجودها بالضبط فيما يتعلق
بالمدن  هذا ما يؤدي إلى
عواقب مدمرة، لذا اشرح
لنا أعني أن مركز الزلزال
مهم بشكل واضح ولكن أيضًا عمق
الزلزال الذي قلته كان
ضحلًا إلى حد معقول، ما الذي يسبب ذلك جيدًا،
الضحالة تجعلها أكثر
قربًا من السكان على عمق كبير
الزلزال سوف يخفف من
الاهتزاز قبل أن يصل إلى السطح،
الزلازل الضحلة تخلق
اهتزازات أقوى في منطقة مركز الزلزال
وهذا ما نشهده الآن لذلك
كان هذا محسوسًا في جميع أنحاء أه المغرب إلى
الشمال إلى إسبانيا وحتى البرتغال
وجنوبًا إلى الجزائر
بصمة واسعة جدًا من الاهتزاز ولكن
الاهتزاز الأقوى كان بالتأكيد في
جبال الأطلس في المنطقة الوسطى العليا
على الرغم من أننا نرى أضرارًا في مراكش
التي أعتقد أنها تبعد 75 كيلومترًا،
حسنًا أخبرنا بما يمكن أن تتوقعه المنطقة
في الساعات والأيام القادمة  فيما
يتعلق بالهزات الارتدادية، مزيد من النشاط
حتى الآن، لقد سجلنا فقط
قوة واحدة أه قريبة من خمسة 4.9
هزة ارتدادية، هناك بالتأكيد المزيد من
الهزات الارتدادية التي تحدث أقل من
عتبتنا، ونتوقع أن تستمر تلك الهزات
وربما أكثر من 925
زلازل أكبر  ممكن اه وبالتالي فإن
التحدي هنا هو أنه بالطبع
حدث هذا في الساعة 11 ليلاً
وكان الكثير من الناس بالداخل في ذلك الوقت
وفي الليل من الصعب الحصول على الكثير من
المعلومات من الميدان
وأعتقد  سنرى أه خسائر وخسائر
تتزايد مع رؤية ضوء النهار، نعم هناك
شيء واحد ننظر إليه، وهو أننا ننظر إلى
الفيديو الذي كنت تشير إليه من قبل
حول بعض هذه المباني التي
أه على الأقل تضررت أو
انهارت جزئيًا و و  لقد أوضحت أن
الأمر يعتمد حقًا على مكان وجوده،
أليس كذلك لأن هناك الكثير من
المباني التاريخية في المغرب،
المباني القديمة أه ولم يتم بناؤها وفقًا
للمعايير التي كانت موجودة منذ
فترة طويلة ولكن لم يتم بناؤها وفقًا للمعايير التي نراها
اليوم
هذا صحيح، أه كما تعلم فإن
ميزة الهياكل هي أحد
العوامل ولكن أيضًا نوع البناء
وعدد من أنواع
البناء هنا
معرضة للخطر للغاية حتى مع بعض
الهياكل الأحدث